viennent donc effectivement après les
échanges très intéressants que nous
avons eu essentiellement sur nos
fonctionnaires je me permets simplement
d'ajouter une chose c'est que beaucoup
d'entre eux aspirent à être plus
efficaces et aspirant à une plus grande
mobilité dans leur carrière puisque
imaginer faire pendant 40 ans la même
chose au sein de la fonction publique
c'est pour beaucoup
quelque chose qui est compliqué lorsque
le conçoit dans une perspective de se
mettre au service de l'état ou de la
chose publique et que je crois qu'on a
un travail très important à faire là
dessus ce qui nous conduit tout
naturellement au deuxième volet qui
celui de l'organisation et de la
structuration de l'état mais aussi des
fonctions publiques territoriale et pour
ce faire donc je suis accompagné ici de
jacques alain benisti qui est déjà
intervenu et nous allons appeler
également xavier peneau qui est
directeur général des services du
conseil général de l'oise
michel rousseau président de la
fondation concorde un jean marc daniel
économiste de l'institut de l'entreprise
on va essayer d'aborder les choses sous
trois angles différents et le premier
c'est donc la question de l'amélioration
de la performance de l'action publique
au travers des réorganisations qu'on
peut envisager de cette même fonction
publique et en guise d'introduction
avant de laisser la parole à nos
orateurs moi je voudrais pointé deux
axes de progrès qui me semble important
au travers de quelques exemples ça a été
évoqué on est dans une période où il ya
eu énormément de réorganisation et
notamment sur la partition des
compétences entre l'état les
collectivités territoriales et notamment
les niveaux régionaux régional
départemental et du bloc communal cette
clarification n'est pas aboutie et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec des
aberrations dont je veux simplement vous
livrer en pâture quelques exemples qui
me sont issus de mon expérience
personnelle d'élu local et des deux
députés au niveau de l'état
c'est peut-être pas parvenue jusqu à
tout le monde mais les mères viennent de
recevoir des courriers de pôle emploi la
plupart des mères viennent de recevoir
des courriers de pôle emploi
indiquant que pour l'emploi pour des
raisons d'organisation interne n'allez
plus pouvoir être ouverts toute la
journée et que donc les maires à partir
de midi étaient priés de bien vouloir
organiser la permanence de pôle emploi
et donc assumer d'algérie mais c'est
véridique assumer dans leur mairie
les après midi l'accueil téléphonique et
l'accueil physique beau on peut quand
même s'interroger sur la place de
l'usager de pôle emploi dans une période
où nous avons six millions de personnes
qui sont à la recherche de travail en
france qu'à l'administration qui est
chargée de les accueillir et de les
orienter ferme ses portes à midi pour
des raisons d'organisation interne
qu'est ce que j'ai fait moins que député
j'ai écrit immédiatement emmené à mme la
ministre du travail qui ne m'a toujours
pas répondu ça fait un mois pour lui
demander de quoi il s'agissait et puis
j'ai écrit au préfet de mon département
qui lors d'une réunion m'a fait un clin
d'oeil en me disant j'ai bien reçu votre
lettre mais je sais pas trop quoi en
faire monsieur le député je suis désolé
deuxième exemple que je vous donne la
dréal qui est l'organisme chargé de la
mise en oeuvre de toutes les
dispositions environnementales est un
organisme qui intervient sur tous les
territoires départementaux communaux
pour venir
réglementer le fonctionnement des
entreprises notamment mais qui est
complètement déconnecté de l'autorité
préfectorale départementale et qui du
coup par exemple récemment dans mon
département est sur le point d'engendrer
la fermeture d'une entreprise où il ya
35 emplois parce qu'un peu trop de
poussière et qui sortent de la cheminée
et que le chef d'entreprise veut se
mettre aux normes mais ne l'a pas fait
d'aller délai tout à fait réglementaire
personne n'a d'autorité sur ses
fonctionnaires ils sont en train
d'engendrer des procédures qui sont à
tel point pénalisante que le chef
d'entreprise va mettre la clé sous la
porte
il suffit d'allumer la télévision pour
un nombre des exemples comme ça partout
troisième exemple au niveau
départemental
le service départemental d'architecturé
patrimoine le fameux architecte des
bâtiments de france qui est directement
rattaché au ministère de la culture qui
n'a rien à voir avec les autorités
préfectorales qui vient vous dire pour
ceux d'entre vous qui êtes mère dans les
communes que vous ne pouvez pas faire
ceci que vous ne pouvez pas faire cela
et que l'église que vous entendez rénové
qui a toujours été un père apparente va
devoir être ensuite parce qu'il a décidé
qu'elle allait être en 8
et vous vous avez la population vent
debout contre cette disposition
donc je pose deux questions que je vais
bien sûr laissé le soin à mes
partenaires ici à la table ronde de
commenter c'est de savoir est ce qu'on
ne doit pas travailler sur une révision
complète des compétences qu'assument les
différentes fonctions publiques pour que
les choses soient claires et du niveau
d'autorité qui les régit dont je pense à
titre personnel qu'il doit être le plus
possible un niveau d'autorité de
proximité et deux no fonction publique
quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs ne sont
elles pas trop autocentrés au détriment
de l'usager voilà alors pour commencer à
répondre à ces questions et puis à
commenter tout ça je donne la parole à
monsieur xavier peneau directeur général
des services du conseil départemental de
l'oise
merci monsieur le député je pense que je
m'exprimerai davantage en qualité
d'ancien préfet sur les structures de
l'administration de l'état plutôt que de
l'actuel directeur général des services
du département de l'oise
si vous permettez quelques réflexions un
peu dans le désordre mais la première et
pardonnez-moi d'enfoncer une porte
ouverte c'est que je pense que le nombre
de services donc le nombre d'agents donc
le nombre de politiques publiques qui
sont portées par ces agents dépend avant
tout du nombre de ministres du nombre de
secrétaires d'état et du nombre de
ministères et de secrétariat d'état
plus il ya deux ministres plus il y à de
nouvelles politiques publiques
plus il ya de nouveaux textes plus il ya
de nouvelles normes et présidé à des
services dédiés et donc il est illusoire
à mon avis de vouloir réduire l'émission
de l'état exercée est donc plus ou moins
bien d'ailleurs avec le nombre de avec
le nombre la restriction des moyens de
vouloir réduire l'émission de l'état si
on ne réduit pas au sommet le nombre de
prescrit de prescripteurs le deuxième la
deuxième observation je voudrais faire
c'est au niveau local sur les structures
de l'administration locale je crois
qu'il l'a il faut il faudra savoir faire
des choix
il est tout à fait légitime de
revendiquer un service public de
proximité
il est tout à fait légitime de
revendiquer une couverture la plus fine
possible du territoire et notamment
vous le savez mieux que moi il y à pas
mal de zones qui sont en déshérence
notamment les zones rurales dans notre
pays mais en même temps vouloir un
service public de proximité vouloir avec
des moyens qui se réduisent un
éparpillement de ses moyens donc
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie et
et d'animer et de coûts pour animer ces
services qui sont dispersés sur le
territoire
c'est un tout petit peu contradictoire
un bel exemple d'ailleurs deux occasions
manquées c'est l'actuelle réforme des
régions le redécoupage des régions et
notamment l'adaptation des services de
l'état ont re découpage des régions pour
des raisons évidentes parce qu'on n'a
pas voulu faire de peine à tel ou tel
parce qu'on n'a pas voulu obliger des
fonctionnaires à une mobilité
on a en fait continuer de la même
dispersion alors que les régions se
concentre
la même dispersion des services de
l'état des services régionaux de l'état
sur le territoire et c'est une à nouveau
une occasion manquée en ce qui concerne
le niveau départemental mon sentiment
prochain compte ancien que en temps en
tant qu'ancien préfet pardon c'est que
au niveau de l'administration
territoriale de l'état départementale on
est à peu près arrivé au taquet les
préfectures n'ont plus guère de moyens
je pense qu'il faudrait aller au fond au
bout de la logique c'est à dire je vais
tout à fait dans votre sens monsieur le
député c'est à dire faire une
administration unique donner la main au
préfet sur l'ensemble des
administrations territoriales et
notamment des débits dans les
départements et mieux organisés et mieux
coordonner ce qui reste de services de
l'état dans les départements au niveau
des départements collectivités locales
je vous ferai simplement par d'une d'une
inquiétude que vous reconnaissez que
vous partagez c'est la prolifération l
augmentation d administration du fait de
la création des communautés de communes
et du fait que la réforme de
l'administration départementale et la
réforme ô combien intéressante du
conseiller territorial n'a pas été mené
à son terme et au contraire été annulés
pour terminer je voudrais juste vous
faire part de ce qui me semble devoir
constituer trois points de vigilance
le premier c'est que il faut que nous
gardions que nous préservions une
fonction publique de qualité
je suis partisan de conserver les nappes
pardon c'est un plaidoyer pro domo
nous avons une fonction publique luc
chatel l'a souligné tout à l'heure et
d'autres intervenants de grande qualité
donc ne jetons pas le bébé avec l'eau du
bain et sion le préserver cette fonction
publique qu'on nous envie le deuxième
point de vigilance c'est qu'à mon avis
il faudra supprimer beaucoup de
démembrement de l'état qui sommes
man généré beaucoup de création de
services que ce soit les offices à
maîtrisable sur le terrain pour un
préfet que ce soit les hautes autorités
diverses et variées qui affaiblissent
l'état et qui contredit sa politique
parfois est en tout cas alourdissent les
structures administratives souvent
et puis pour répondre à la question qui
était posée dans l'intitulé de la table
ronde
la performance est ce qu'il est
nécessaire de créer une direction
générale de la performance je n'aurais
pas l'outrecuidance de répondre à la
question simplement je constate qu'il ya
une foultitude d'organismes de
compétences le siamap la direction du
budget la cour des comptes les corps
d'inspection ils sont nombreux et que
plus que la multiplication de ces de ces
organismes de contrôle de la performance
je crois qu'il faut surtout qu'on est à
l'esprit ce que nous essayons de faire
notre modeste échelle dans le
département de l'oise d'évaluer
systématiquement systématiquement toutes
les politiques publiques qui sont mises
en place
après quelques mois d'expérimentation et
cette évaluation systématique permet
justement d'apprécier la performance et
ensuite de mettre ou non un terme à
l'expérience lancée
merci beaucoup monsieur rousseau
président de la fondation concorde
si vous voulez d'abord nous dire un mot
de ce qu'est la fondation concorde
l'impression qu'on corps est un think
tank généralistes proche des idées des
républicains et du centre qui a été créé
il ya une quinzaine d'années donc nous
sommes pratiquement les plus anciens et
nous avons une soixantaine de d'experts
personnalités qui répartis sur une
dizaine de sujets qui couvre l'ensemble
des politiques en général avec au départ
deux préoccupations majeures qui n'ont
pas changé depuis 15 ans 1 la réduction
de la dépense publique et 2
la reconstruction ou la consolidation de
notre système de production depuis 15
ans donc si on en juge par les résultats
actuels nous n'avons pas été très
efficaces mais nous avons contribué à
diffuser dans la le monde dans l'opinion
et parmi les décideurs politiques nous
avons contribué à diffuser cette
préoccupation que nous traitons
aujourd'hui on a le premier rapport sur
la réduction de la dépense publique a
été fait chez nous en 99 et il a été
signé par yves cannac était ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée il kanak
trouver une relation une corrélation
très forte entre niveau de la dépense
publique et niveau de chômage à l'époque
pourrait refaire cette corrélation
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'on doit pas
être très loin de ça donc là la
fondation concorde joue un rôle
permanent auprès des décideurs
nous avons le plus grand respect pour
les élus c'est un métier extrêmement
difficile et nous sommes avant tout des
gens de réflexion et nous n'avons aucune
prétention à occuper le champ politique
au contraire nous sommes au service de
nos amis qui prennent des
responsabilités et qui donc sont amenés
à gérer le pays
simplement nous sommes une courroie de
transmission une espèce de comité de
soutien d'encouragement à la réforme
ok voilà alors si vous voulez aller sur
le site de la fondation concorde vous
verrez qu'on a beaucoup d'activités
nous avons trois mille
adhérents dans la région parisienne
17000 relais d'opinion en france nous
avons 80 publications derrière nous et
un ensemble de communication mais je
pense que nous sommes de plus en plus
connu et donc je vais tout de suite
passé à la question qui vous intéresse
et qui intéresse nos amis alors dans
l'état actuel de notre pays
la fondation concorde pense que la
modernisation du pays se résume à
obtenir une réduction de la dépense
publique conséquente
notre objectif nous c'est la réduction
de la dépense publique
alors vous avez exprimé les uns et les
autres un certain nombre de possibilités
de simplification nous sommes d'accord
mais nous restons nous au niveau global
c'est-à-dire en fait la france a besoin
d'obtenir une réduction sensible de ses
dépenses publiques car de ces économies
tout dépend tout dépend parce que en
premier lieu nous devons nous éloigner
de l'endettement insoutenable vers
lequel nous arrivons tranquillement et
ça c'est insupportable pour un patriote
de se trouver si vous voulez dans une
situation impossible et d'avoir des
difficultés pour rembourser ses dettes
donc la réduction de la dépense publique
est essentiel déjà pour ça dans un
deuxième temps la réduction de la
dépense publique nous permettra de faire
des économies qui pourront être disons
orienté fléchés vers l'allègement des
charges et vert disons une relance de
l'activité en particulier une
consolidation du système productif nous
pensons que il est nécessaire de faire
ce transfert le plus vite possible et
donc d'obtenir des résultats
les groupes de travail qui réunit des
hauts fonctionnaires expérimentés
actuellement encore dans les services et
des économistes et des élus j'ai été élu
mois mer pendant 29 ans donc j'ai vu la
dérive en 29 ans de relations entre les
collectivités territoriales et
l'administration
j'ai vu le dénuement progressive des
préfets qui donc il ya une partie de
restauration de l'état mais c'est une
deuxième phase nous ne pensons que
d'entrée il faut être énergique et se
donner des objectifs sans se donner des
objectifs ya aucune raison qu'on les
atteignent nous avons comme objectif
ce que les autres d'ailleurs candidats à
la primaire ont presque tous ont entre 4
et 5 points de pib c'est à dire de 57 on
voudrait revenir à 51.5 ou à 52% au
rythme de 20 22 milliards par an nos
experts qui sont en exercice
actuellement et qui ont décrit la
méthode qui est une méthode qui concerne
avant tout les administrations centrales
où les grandes administrations mais les
trois il ya aussi les collectivités
locales et il ya le la sphère sociale
bien entendu nous nous avons comme
objectif chaque année environ 22
milliards avec les avec les efforts sur
la sphère sociale on arrive au total à
80 entre 80 et 90 milliards sur cinq ans
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire les
deux ou trois mesures de réforme de
l'administration que vous jugez utiles
médiatement efficace pour atteindre ces
objectifs de voir le gel de tout
recrutement dans la fonction publique
pendant trois ans
c'est donc pas le un sur deux et nous
pensons que c'est nécessaire sur deux a
montré ses limites
nous sommes contre la politique du
grignotage et du rabot qui
déséquilibrent certains services et qui
ne tient pas compte de la réalité des
effectifs dans les administrations et en
termes organisationnels puisqu'on est
dense était alors assez haut sur la
performance et l'efficacité
alors en termes organisationnel nous
pensons que c'est réalisable avec dans
chaque ministère un pôle réforme
constitué de hauts fonctionnaires
réformateur et puis associé à des
parlementaires parce qu'il va falloir
faire ça doit être accompagnée d'une
réorganisation profonde du système non
seulement une simplification mais
parfois aussi l'annulation d'un certain
nombre d'omissions nous sommes pour la
suppression de mission la suppression de
guichet la suppression de contrôle
donc c'est là c'est le contrôle
parlementaire qui assurerait une
transversalité parce que la grosse
difficulté c'est de ne pas regarder un
décloisonnement absolument ceux qui se
font au détriment de la de monsieur
décrites et les parlementaires devront
mouiller leur chemise pour aller dans
les ministères accompagné accompagner
les réformateurs les hauts
fonctionnaires en place qui auront cette
charge
disons de simplifier de réduire les
effectifs
moi j'ai participé une carrière
d'universitaire mme à la fin j'ai été
nommé au contrôle général des allergies
pp j'ai donc suivi la rgpp pendant
plusieurs mois
je trouve que la rgpp et est formidable
parce que elle a fait surgir des
compétences dans les services la faire
paraître des gens remarquables et bien
coeur au total a pas été très efficace
la preuve c'est que l'on reparle
aujourd'hui mais je trouve qu'elle a
créé du mouvement dans les services elle
a eu un effet extraordinaire de mise en
évidence que il n'y avait pas que la
haute fonction publique était
performante et compétente mais il y
avait aussi dans les services des gens
formidables et ne pas recruter pendant
trois ans dans la fonction publique vous
de créer un appel d'air formidable les
gens qui vont prendre des
responsabilités nouvelles qui vont
sortir de leur administration qui vont
dépasser leur statut il va falloir
mettre un peu de démocratie dans tout ça
est juste pour conclure est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous êtes favorable
ou pas à la création d'une direction de
la performance publique
ce qu'on appelle l'équivalent du sénat
aux britanniques
oui mais en fait en gros nous ce qu'on
propose c'est donc le couplage entre
hauts fonctionnaires compétents pour la
réforme et parlementaires on préfère
avoir ça dans chaque ministère avec des
objectifs précis
nous croyons aux objectifs des objectifs
qui soient bien exposé avant et qu'ils
soient bien définis la méthode vous la
trouverez dans le fascicule de la
fondation concorde qui va paraître dans
quinze jours trois semaines et qui vous
donnera une déroulement voilà merci
beaucoup d'ailleurs certaines personnes
ici qui ont participé à ces travaux et
nous les en remercions
merci beaucoup monsieur daniel oui moi
je comme beaucoup de choses ont été
dites et qu'on attend le président
sarkozy je ne veux pas manger sur son
temps je vais faire juste trois
remarques la première marque en ce qui
concerne la définition des objectifs
moi je me méfie des objectifs qui
consiste à vouloir faire la même chose
que l'allemagne pouvoir faire la même
chose que le l'espagne et puis avoir le
même taux de dépenses publiques tel ou
tel pays quand on dit ça aux gens les
gens ils vous disent mais je ne suis pas
allemand et en allemagne tel service est
pris en charge par l'état telle autre
service et privés alors que chez nous
c'est pas exactement la même chose dont
je pense que l'objectif ne doit pas se
définit en point depuis par comparaison
avec d'autres pays l'objectif de se
définir par rapport au fait que comme le
disait luc chatel vous avez coût
efficacité et donc au travers de nos
impôts nous achetons des services
publics et la question qui se pose c'est
est ce que nous en avons pour notre
argent est la première mesure de la face
à la réalité que nous appréhendons de
cette efficacité relative et du fait que
nous en ayons de notre chance est ce que
nous payons ce que l'état est censé nous
donner
et la réponse est non à l'heure actuelle
nous ne payons pas à hauteur de ce que
l'état est censé nous donner puisque
l'état est en déficit
si tu es donc je pense que le seul
véritable et premier objectif ça doit
être d'équilibrer les comptes publics
c'est à dire de faire en sorte que quand
on paie ce qui est un regard
correspondra exactement ce que l'on a
payé et donc je pense que nous devons
respecter les traités européens
c'est-à-dire faire qu'il n'y ait plus
qu'un déficit qu'ils soient liés à vos
évolutions conjoncturelles mais que le
déficit de long terme le déficit
structurel soit égal à zéro le premier
indicateur que l'on doit avoir c'est que
or là les traces du temps dans le budget
c'est hier or la charge d'intérêt les
services publics d'aujourd'hui soient
payés par les impôts d'aujourd'hui donc
non seulement nous devons avoir déficit
structurel égal à zéro parce que ça
correspond à une réalité économique et
parce que nous avons signé un traité
européen dans ce sens mais nous devons
faire en sorte que la génération
d'aujourd'hui tu es les services publics
de la génération d'aujourd'hui est donc
de faire que ce que les économistes
appellent le solde primaire soit égal à
zéro or à l'heure actuelle nous sommes
en déficit primaire est en déficit
structurel donc le premier objectif
c'est pas de faire comme l'allemagne
le premier objectif c'est de faire en
sorte que comme on l'a dit les services
publics d'aujourd'hui sont payés par les
contribuables mais qui commence pas à
payer par les contribuables
d'aujourd'hui est pas les contribuables
de demain donc le premier objectif le
seul objectif pour moi c'est
d'équilibrer les finances publiques et
de commencer à avoir comme premier
objectif d'équilibrer le solde primaire
le deuxième élément sur l'analyse de
l'efficacité tout ça il ya une seule
fois jusqu'à présent seule une fois que
un mot a été lâché par le eric woerth il
a dit on va mettre le centre de
formation des agents territoriaux en
concurrence mais je dis mais pourquoi le
centre de formation des agents
territoriaux
mais on va mettre tout le monde en
concurrence parce que la deuxième façon
de vérifier si quelque chose est
efficace c'est de le comparer à ce que
proposent d'autres personnes et donc la
seule façon de vérifier si un service
public et efficace c'est de le mettre en
concurrence avec d'autres services
publics et donc je pense que le
véritable enjeu c'est pas de dégrader
par ci par là en disant on va supprimer
une infirmière à tel endroit et tout ça
le véritable enjeu c'est de dire écoutez
si vous n'êtes pas capable de faire ce
qu'on vous demande quelqu'un d'autre va
le faire à votre place et donc je pense
que il faut raisonner dans un état
maître d'ouvragé et non plus dans un
état maître d'oeuvre un état qui donne
des grandes orientations et qui en suit
pas
une multitude de contrats avec tout un
tas d'organismes qui sont susceptibles
de faire ce travail
deux exemples concrets je pense on est
s'est engagé dans la voie de l'autonomie
des universités on est passé de
l'autonomie à la féodalité
je ne sais pas si vous avez mesuré que
l'actuel président de l'unef
il a 27 ans bon 27 ans il est en master
1 à 27 ans mais ce que je trouve le plus
scandaleux c'est qu'il a un master
d'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
quoi de l'économie sociale et solidaire
mais qu'est ce qu'il est en train
d'apprendre cet individu et il fait ça
avec des crédits publics qu'ils aient
envie va prendre l'économie sociale et
solidaire pourquoi pas s'il ya une
instance privée qui se met sur le marché
en disant moi je vais apprendre
l'économie sociale et solidaire
il ya des gens qui ont envie de la
prendre il ya des gens qui ont envie de
s'en servir il ya des gens qui ont envie
de l'utiliser
pourquoi pas mais qu'on le fasse dans un
cadre on impose à la population de payer
un individu à 27 ans pour faire quelque
chose qui ne sert à rien c'est
insupportable et donc il faut mettre en
concurrence systématiquement tout ce
monde universitaire on est parti dans
une mécanisme qui au nom de l'autonomie
est allé vers la féodalité il faut
casser la féodalité la seule façon de
casser la féodalité c'est de confier une
gestion privé concurrentiel l'ensemble
des services publics qui peuvent l'être
troisième élément à partir de ce moment
là quelle est la méthode mais on a déjà
privatisés des choses quand luc chatel
dit écouter mais à la poste il ya 90
milles facteurs qui servent à rien donc
on est en train de réfléchir à comment
les utiliser moi je sais comment les
utiliser un plan social et ils font
autre chose simplement pour faire un
plan social il faut privatiser la poste
on l'a déjà fait on a privatisé france
télécom et on a privatisé français comme
on a dit aux agents des télécoms ceux
qui rentrent plus de statut ceux qui ont
le statut vous avez le choix avec plus
de statut et puis les autres on les met
en extension on peut faire ça on l'a
fait à france télécom on peut faire ça
dans l'éducation le royaume uni l'a fait
le royaume uni a supprimé 400 mille
emplois dans la fonction publique
l'essentiel ont été supprimées par
transformation de statut de gens qui ont
préféré choisir un statut de nature
prisé dans des organisations qui gère
maintenant pour l'essentiel la formation
notamment au travers du système des free
school
donc les gens sont demandeurs de ça les
gens attendent la concurrence
par rapport à la méthode alors juste un
exemple pour le fait que les gens
attendent la concurrence pour le faire
le plaisir un peu fun quand le président
de l'assemblée nationale socialiste
convaincu et militants du service public
à des problèmes de santé
il va à l'hôpital américain de neuilly
il va pas dans le service public
il fait jouer la concurrence donc la
confiance tout le monde est prêt à
accepter la concurrence même les plus
pire borné de l'ailé gauche du parti
socialiste
il accepte la concurrence dont le seul
moyen effectivement maintenant se
réfléchir à la réforme de l'état c'est
comment on va passer à la concurrence
et alors on va passer à la concurrence
de façon progressive
juste une dernière remarque dans la
méthode de la réforme
je pense qu'une erreur dans tout ce qui
a été fait jusqu'à présent dans la
méthode de la réforme c'est de raisonner
comme dans horace de corneille
on va régler les problèmes les uns après
les autres si vous régler les problèmes
les uns après les autres vous donner le
sentiment à tout corps social qui n'est
pas impacté par la réforme que tout
corps social qui est impactée par la
réforme qui en a d'autres qui sont
privilégiés qui sont protégés qui sont
en situation rend pierre est donc un
véritable problème de réforme c'est un
problème de réforme qui est un problème
de réformes qui concernent tout le monde
il faut faire exploser la rente du
service public et du secteur public au
travers du statut de la fonction
publique
au même moment que la rente du
pharmacien que la rente du notaire que
la rente du monopole de la sncf sur les
transports la loi macron c'était un
point de départ
le dommage c'est que dans la loi macro
e-bay 308 articles mais 3080 article
pour balayer tout ça pour occuper pour
les 3080 article aurait pu résumer en un
seul article
la liberté économique conformément au
décret le chapelier de 1790 et rétabli
dans ce pays merci
merci beaucoup on va appeler à nous
rejoindre donc hervé mariton député de
la drôme
dorothée pineau directrice générale
voilà oui on va peut-être faire un petit
roulement
dorothée pinon directrice générale
adjointe du medef et gilles havre ou
maire de châteauroux
bonjour voila prenez place et on va donc
maintenant aborder les deux derniers
sujets de cette table ronde qui tourne
autour de la question des normes
administratives et aussi de l'évolution
des pratiques notamment avec le
numérique et je laisse la parole tout de
suite à jacques alain bénisti sur les
norns bien ben écoutez mes chers amis il
faut savoir que le stock de normes
applicables en france étaient estimés
par le cd e en 2007 à près de dix mille
cinq cents loi et 120 milles décret et
ce chiffre a augmenté de 20 % depuis
2007 et moi je me souviens et je pense
que sébastien huyghe s'en souvient
également à la commission des lois
nous avions décidé la commission des
lois de faire un véritable nettoyage de
l'ensemble des doit d'abord des lois que
nous avions en stock mais qui n'avait
jamais été validées par des décrets donc
qu'ils n'étaient pas appliquées et un
certain nombre de lois qui faisait
doublon va voir triple je dirais
concernant un certain nombre de missions
et bien nous avions décidé finalement de
nettoyer complètement ses lois et la
gestion publique et bien sûr les
administrés et les français en général
n'en peuvent plus évidemment avec
l'accumulation de toutes ces
réglementations
c'est la conséquence donc de l'absence
de réforme des administrations centrales
qui vraiment le point essentiel de ces
problématiques et pour redonner
justement aux citoyens comme aux agents
publics d'ailleurs les marges de
manoeuvre et les capacités d'initiative
dans lesquelles il n'y a pas d'activité
donc efficace il est je pense
indispensable de desserrer l'étau
réglementaire alors le conseil d'état
dernièrement à recommander une réforme
radicale consistant à limiter ce qu'on
appelle souvent le droit dur à la
formation et à la formulation des
objectifs et des existences essentiel
des politiques en renvoyant la
définition de leurs voies d'exécution à
ce qu'on appellerait désormais du droit
souple sans force évidemment obligatoire
et ça c'est un changement c'est une
métamorphose véritablement dans tout les
systèmes de nos administrations et ce
droit souple prendra la forme de
référentiels donc de méthodes destinées
à aider les agents à être plus efficaces
d'abord à l'instar des référentiels du
monde des entreprises est évidemment à
essayer d'évacuer toutes ces différentes
réglementations donc au sein des
républicains nous avons évidemment
travailler donc sur ces sujets et nous
avons donc deux propositions dans une
optique d'abord de simplification il
nous faut élaborer ce qu'on appelle la
politique de sunset clause qu'on a parlé
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure agnès verdier
nous à nous en a parlé dans son
préliminaire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
eh bien c'est tout simplement qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya une nouvelle loi
aucune nouvelle réglementation ou normes
rentrer en application sera votée par le
liquidateur et bien il faudra y
appliquer obligatoirement une date
d'expiration
à l'image d'une date limite de
consommation sur les produits
alimentaires ou des mesures fiscales
spécifiques et loi scellier les lois
borloo etc
c'est un système qui était mise en place
donc en angleterre par david cameron
pour chaque nouvelle réglementation
votée on en supprime une plus ancienne
c'est un principe de bonne
administration qu'il faut mettre donc
désormais aux neuf
ensuite il faut également rendre
obligatoire
dans les deux mois la promulgation des
décrets et des textes d'application
la france malheureusement un système
digestif souffre malheureusement du fait
qu' on vote des lois quelquefois qui met
un temps d'ailleurs être adoptée et les
décrets interviennent quelques fois un
an à un an et demi et on l'a vu
dernièrement que je ne sais plus quel
texte ou le décret est intervenue deux
ans avant le vote à l'assemblée
nationale et en août
donc il est urgent de résoudre ce
problème du travail en silo des
ministères des administrations qui pour
un même territoire multiplie les
dispositions réglementaires et
législatives au risque et on voit
notamment dernièrement avec certaines
mesures sur l'agriculture de conduire
comme on le voit souvent à des
incohérences et la prise en compte des
particularités locales doit donc être
avant tout la première des priorités
nous ne pouvons plus imaginer que ces
réglementations agricoles
environnementales soient parfaitement
identiques pour des territoires aussi
variés sans tenir compte des handicaps
géographique ou de la topologie donc de
la région la deuxième proposition que
nous faisons pour les pluies car c'est
de mettre en place une véritable
politique d'évaluation continue ce qu'on
appelle le système open data il faut
permettre donc une transparence totale
et une comparaison des données et des
résultats publics entre eux le
développement de l'open data doit être
poursuivie et y sera inévitablement
d'ailleurs un levier extraordinaire
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
par dell les usagers eux mêmes et
permettra l'amélioration est évidemment
la qualité des services publics qu'on ne
cesse de parler depuis 2
le début de nos échanges donc c'est
cette politique d'évaluation renforcer
et continue des politiques publiques en
y associant évidemment bien sûr le
parlement et la cour des comptes que les
français nous pensons renoueront une
vraie confiance avec leur administration
merci beaucoup hervé mariton pardon
merci à toi merci ardo le thème de la
matinée qu'il est extrêmement important
je suis allé pour nourrir une réflexion
sur la réforme de la fiscalité en
estonie il ya dix jours l'estonie a
instauré une carte d'identité numérique
qui permet qui permet aux citoyens
estoniens des rapports extrêmement
fluide extrêmement efficace avec
l'administration dans un pays dont la
dette est limité à 10% du produit
intérieur brut
quasiment 100% en france et comme cela a
été évoqué dans la table ronde
précédente
un pays qui connaît l'équilibré
budgétaire un pays qui d'ailleurs
propose aux citoyens français toi nous
tous pouvons demain obtenir une identité
numérique estonienne et à partir de
cette identité numérique développer
notre business reste un sombre de
questions de fiscalité
les estoniens font semblant de dire nous
vous rappelons que la fiscalité doit
être payé dans le pays où vous avez
votre activité physique je suis pas sûr
qu'ils le vérifie au quotidien je veux
dire par là que si nous n'engageons pas
ce type de révolution alors de petits
pays comme l'estonie ou deux plus grands
pays peuvent mettre totalement à bas
notre équilibre économique déséquilibres
actuels mais la prospérité que nous
voulons retrouver et ça passe en effet
par une révolution de la nature de nos
relations avec l'administration
ça va avec un sombre de réformes je suis
attaché à réformer la fiscalité vers un
impôt universel et proportionnel la flat
tax
mais c'est cohérent c'est cohérent y
compris en économies de dépenses
publiques en économie de fonctionnaires
on a aujourd'hui encore plus de sous
contrôle d'eric plus de cent mille
fonctionnaires des impôts dans notre
pays une réforme fiscale type impôt
universel et proportionnel une évolution
de fiscalité des entreprises
tout le monde constate la réforme était
pas inintéressante mais elle est
imparfaite
ce qui a été c'était bien de s'attaquer
et ça a été fait sous mandat précédent à
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle
mais la cvae et la contribution foncière
des entreprises sont des systèmes
extrêmement coûteux en termes
d'évaluation et de vérification on ne
peut pas se permettre d'avoir un système
fiscal qui soit si content si coûteux en
emploi public
un point qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un sujet dans
le pays pour avancer s'était dit tout à
l'heure et et c'était très bien sur la
mobilisation du parlement et je pense
c'est ce qui se fait au royaume uni mais
un meilleur on a plutôt évolué dans le
sens d'un plus grand travail de la cour
des comptes avec le parlement je pense
qu un rattachement de la cour des
comptes au parlement me donner beaucoup
plus d'effets à ses préconisations sur
l'évolution des rapports entre les
citoyens et l'administration encore ça a
été très bien dit la liberté la liberté
et jean marc daniel a insisté là dessus
c'est par exemple dans le domaine des
politiques culturelles la culture
nicolas sarkozy le dit très bien est un
bien de première nécessité
est-ce que ça justifie pour autant
l'administration culturelle qu'on a
développé les architectes des bâtiments
de france ont été évoqués tout à l'heure
la réponse est non
je pense que beaucoup de réponses
passent par des formules libéral du type
chèques culture qui fait que plutôt que
d'avoir une administration qui prend sa
part sur ce qu'est la politique
culturelle de la france et ça coûte et
ça crée des rugosités des délais une
part d'une efficacité pour le coup le
citoyen peut être libres de décider
livre de savoir s'ils financent ou pas
l'expo du vagin de la reine à versailles
ou en tout cas un citoyen qui soit
véritablement est directement décideurs
de la dépense publique
semblablement dans le domaine de
l'éducation
et s'agissant des normes on a déjà parlé
quelques fois avec dorothée 1 oui
la simplification je suis rapporteur du
budget de l'écologie à la commission des
finances
quand j'ai voulu attaquer ce problème on
me dira monsieur mariton le bo
simplification dans le domaine de
l'écologie c'est interdit on peut et va
mes textos ou les amis on peut
éventuellement parler de modernisation
mais la simplification surtout pas
d'évidence si déjà les responsables
politiques n'assument pas les mots en
amont il n'y a aucune espèce de raison
si on sait pas ce qu'on veut convient
yves clairement ça vaut pour l'écologie
mais c'est un impact sur la vie des
entreprises évidemment on en a parlé il
ya quelques semaines s'agissant
d'agriculture et de ruralité
il faut assumer la simplification et ce
qui va avec comment il faut regarder des
choses très précise très pointue mais
qui ont leur importance
pourquoi est-ce qu'en france on sur
transpose aussi fréquemment les
directives communautaires
1 est ce qu'on joue tous notre rôle dans
la négociation des directives
communautaires
est ce que la france joue pleinement son
rôle à bruxelles on l'a vu tragiquement
ces derniers jours avec l'enjeu des
migrants la réponse hélas et non la
france n'est pas à la hauteur de ses
responsabilités et de ses intérêts mais
deux de manière beaucoup plus technique
j'ai découvert c'est pointu mais c'est
important que la direction qui négocient
la directive au sein du rpt d'un
ministère n'est pas la même que celle
qui la transpose n'est pas la même que
celle qui la contrôle
admettons monsieur le préfet la
différence entre le contrôle et la mise
en oeuvre mais si celui qui négocie et
qui est donc a compris les enjeux de je
te donne tu me donnes n'ait pas ensuite
en ordre avec celui qui transpose alors
on donne on négocie et on se fait avoir
au moment de la transposition et il faut
pas être surpris de ces sur
transposition qui sont handicapantes
ruineuse et qui coûtent souvent ce que
guillaume poitrinal que valérie pécresse
a mobilisé en ile de france dit si bien
qu'ils coûtent des délais
supplémentaires à la vie économique de
notre pays et ses délais c'est la
croissance gâché et de l'emploi gâché et
faire enfin s'agissant des normes mais
ça demande beaucoup de nerfs et beaucoup
de volonté qu'on est véritablement une
culture des résultats et qu'on arrête de
s'abriter derrière des parapluies je
pourrais vous donner des exemples y
compris les exemples très vécu en ce
moment même en tant que maire de créer
la culture du résultat ça doit être la
manière de comprendre et de mettre en
oeuvre les normes elles sont pas
toujours si mal écrite cependant et
elles sont parfois en tout cas écrite en
résultats mais vous trouvez avec une
démarche au sein des administrations qui
fait qu'à mesure que vous rapprocher du
terrain on exige de nous une approche de
méthode et non pas une approche de
résultats mais je peux vous dire alors
que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher aux
contribuables
et c'est bien plus douloureux pour les
entreprises merci à hervé veulent madame
madame pinault oui donc hervé a repris
beaucoup d on accueille notre président
nicolas sarkozy oui donc hervé mariton a
repris beaucoup de propositions du medef
c'est avec le medef
son premier set proxo préoccuper de la
compétitivité du site france et le poids
des normes en france est vraiment
quelque chose qui altèrent cette
compétitivité
on a eu quelques exemples dans les
semaines qui viennent se passer à la
grippe au salon de l'agriculture on a vu
que les normes françaises dans leur
application et leur conception avaient
altéré la compétitivité l'agriculture
française notamment par rapport à
l'agriculture allemande mais dans le
domaine de la construction c'est le coût
de la construction en france et environ
20% supérieur au coût de la construction
allemande et sans résultat particulier
et donc il ya également un problème de
délai les les délais en france pour
sortir un projet guillaume poitrinal
on a beaucoup parlé sont en général de 2
à 3 ans supérieur au délai pour sortir
un projet en allemagne et puis une
dernière constatation la sueur
transposition des directives dont a
parlé hervé nous sommes les champions la
sueur transposition des directives en
france et je suis en particulier effaré
de voir que la présidente de la
commission des affaires européennes qui
est une députée
verte à l'assemblée a déposé une
résolution pour accélérer et accentue
encore cette sueur transposition donc
nous nos propositions au medef c'est
d'abord une méthode nous voudrions
pouvoir créer ce que nous appelons un
comité impact entreprises un ses yeux
pour que toute nouvelle norme
législative et réglementaire soit
évaluée à l'aune de son impact sur la
vie des entreprises
deuxième méthode la proposition mais on
est très proches sur cette table ronde
ensuite l'application de principes le
silence de l'administration vos accords
le principe est formidable la seule
chose c'est que le gouvernement actuel a
mis à peu près de 2500 exception à cette
règle
ce qui évidemment dénature complètement
deux principes le principe dites le nous
une fois ça c'est quelque chose qui est
commencent à rentrer en application
nous voudrions le voir beaucoup mieux
appliquées et surtout un principe
anglais ce n'est pas la seule cette
clause mais c'est un autre principe
principe anglais le one in two out
l'idée que chaque nouvelles normes
réglementaires ou législatives serait
accompagné de la sortie de deux normes
alors en france on essaie déjà de
pousser le one in one out au medef en
tout cas mais le one in toi tu sais
quand même le principe combien en oeuvre
les anglais
depuis dix ans il se rend compte que au
bout de dix ans ça se traduit par de
vraies économies légiste est des
économies budgétaires
et enfin dernière chose s'attaquer aux
stocks et aux flux pour le stock
raccourcir tous les délais
d'autorisation et de recours c'est la
proposition de guillaume poitrinal
supprimer les contrôles a priori par des
contrôles a posteriori
nous voudrions que la france rentre dans
un système de confiance de relations de
confiance avec les entreprises notamment
qu' a priori les particuliers et
entreprises seraient de bonne foi il
devrait donc être contrôlé après et non
pas avant et enfin tout ce qui serait
dématérialisation des procédures pour le
flux nous voudrions x proposition le
député
nous voudrions multiplié les études
d'impact notamment pour tout ce qui est
propositions de lois et amendements
les études d'impact sont aujourd'hui
obligatoire pour les projets de loi et
ne sont pas pour les propositions - qui
peuvent pourtant avoir des effets
si important pour les entreprises que
des projets de loi nous voudrions
également comme vous recourir plus
systématiquement au droit souple
peut-être que ça a été recommandée par
le conseil d'état nous voudrions
multiplier les expérimentations
géographique sa cervelle qu'il a dit est
temporel c'est vous qui l'avez dit nous
voudrions également effectivement des
clauses de limitation des d'applications
dans le temps la scène cette clause des
dispositions de 3 droit transitoire
aussi lorsqu'il ya un changement de
réglementation
nous voudrions des périodes de droit
transitoire pour permettre aux
entreprises de s'adapter
nous voudrions que les projets de
décrets d'application soient présentées
en même temps que des projets de loi
pour qu'on voit effectivement quand
comment les lois seront appliquées et
enfin et c'est aussi une proposition qui
a été faite par hervé mariton
nous voudrions imposer des évaluations
ex post des textes législatifs
merci beaucoup juste avant de
transmettre j'ai juste une remarque tu
m'en voudra pas je veux que la matinée
et passionnante
quelle curieuse idée pour les
républicains de paris du rapport aux
usagers notre vision du rapport aux
citoyens dans la modernisation de l'état
je pense que le mot usagers il ya tout
de même quelques temps qu'en france on a
décidé de passer à quelque chose d'un
peu d'un peu plus dynamique et plus
moderne mais j'ai bravo eric monsieur le
maire de châteauroux merci alors moi je
vais parler de renouvellement
c'est le thème d'aujourd'hui pour une
action publique renouvelé et du
numérique
joe dominique senard le président de
michelin il ya quelques jours disait le
numérique est une véritable révolution
industrielle
bon on doit avoir conscience aujourd'hui
on doit prendre conscience que c'est
aussi devenu une véritable révolution
administrative ça doit l'être tout au
moins dans l'organisation de l'état mais
également dans l'organisation des
collectivités locales aujourd'hui le
numérique les smartphones servent entrer
dans notre quotidien
juste avant que le président sarkozy
rentre chose et le point au premier rang
sur les 12 du premier rang il y avait
neuf qui était en train de regarder leur
soir leur smartphone voilà mais on
aurait retrouvé la même chose à tous les
rangs du public tous les rangs du public
juste avant que le président sarkozy
rentrent aujourd'hui c'est 75 ordre
c'est assez un chiffre 2015 75 % des
foyers ont une connexion internet 2016
on va arriver à près de 80 % 40 % de nos
concitoyens ont fait leur déclaration
d'impôt sur le revenu en ligne et chaque
année on a une progression significative
aujourd'hui les français demandent du
service public en ligne à l'accès à
l'administration 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7
c'est c'est un atout pour nous on disait
tout à l'heure contre on fait face à une
nécessité de baisse de la dépense
publique
moi si je prends l'exemple de
châteauroux ma baisse des dotations
d'état va correspondre à 40% de moins
sur trois en 2015 2016 2017
donc en 2017 je vais percevoir 40 % de
moins que ce que je percevais de l'état
en 2014 ce qui correspond si je voulais
compenser en augmentant les impôts à 20%
d'augmentation des taux d'imposition
je me suis engagé comme nombre d'élus de
chez nous de ne pas augmenter les impôts
pendant le mandat jusqu'à 2020
conclusion je dois faire des économies
ailleurs va les collectivités locales on
a deux solutions pour faire des
économies soins mutualistes des moyens à
l'échelle intercommunale
on ferait une vraie vraie fusion des
échelons intercommunalités ville centre
est et autres communes de l'interco
deuxième moyen c'est la mise en place de
services numériques d'outils numériques
de simplifier la vie de nos concitoyens
je prends un exemple quand j'ai été élu
en 2014
nous avions encore des tickets de
cantine c'est à dire que les habitants
on devait venir à la mairie cherchait à
acheter des tickets aujourd'hui on a
dématérialisé cela l'enfance va à
l'école le matin ils disent yves à la
cantine c'est enregistré on reçoit une
facture à la fin du mois ceux qui
voulaient s'inscrire à la piscine
faisait la queue à partir de 5 heures du
matin parce qu'on n'a pas assez de place
et donc c'était au premier maintenant
tout ça c'est par internet et ça ça
répond vraiment à une demande de
l'usager
le problème c'est qu'au niveau national
on a on n'a pas de pilote je dirais on
n'a pas un ministère chargé de montrer
l'exemple et dire voilà on va développer
ses actions là et on va montrer le bon
exemple à toutes les communes
on disait que l'état réduisait son
nombre de fonctionnaires sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy
mais qu'en parallèle les collectivités
elles avaient elles augmenté leur nombre
d'agents si aujourd'hui on veut que tout
le monde aille dans le même sens et
baisse les effectifs de la fonction
publique il faut avoir un guide de bonne
méthode et il faut qu'on des l'échelon
national qu'on impose la mise en place
de services communs sur tout le
territoire à nos habitants c'est
vraiment une demande mais ça va j'irai
au contact de l'usagé quotidien mais
également sur des cas plus particulier
si on prend sur châteauroux on a deux
établissements pénitentiaires important
on a tous les jours des extractions de
je crois que nicolas sarkozy on a parlé
aussi il ya quelques temps de détenus
pour être emmené au palais de justice
pour rencontrer le juge d'application
des peines si tu as fait des choses qui
pourraient se faire avec une
visioconférence sans avoir à mobiliser
un tas de policiers pour assurer la
sécurité du transport l'allèle retour
c'est tout un tas de choses qui relèvent
du bon sens dont on est nous les élus
locaux je dirai au quotidien auquel on
est confronté où on peut faire des
propositions édicté un guide des bonnes
pratiques nationales et il faut que
l'état soit le pilote en la matière et
qu'on puisse aujourd'hui se met au goût
du jour parce que les habitants sont
bien plus en avance que nous sur les
usages numériques et l'administration
est très en retard donc il ya vraiment
besoin d'une politique nationale et je
crois que votre père républicain là
dessus face aussi à jouer un rôle moteur
c'est l'occasion qui nous est donnée
aujourd'hui de faire des propositions à
la matière il faudra vraiment quand on
sera revenu au pouvoir en 2010 est qu'on
s'attaque prioritairement à cette
question de l'importance et du rôle du
numérique dans le fonctionnement de
l'état et des collectivités locales
parce que c'est une importante source
d'économie et on pourra pas maintenir le
service public un service public de
qualité en diminuant le nombre de
fonctionnaires si derrière on compense
pas avec d'autres outils
merci j
on le fera on le fera ne commettant pas
l'erreur qu'a commise que commettent les
socialistes sous la houlette d'axel le
maire qui nous a présenté sa juste avant
d'aller accoucher de mettre au 23e
article du troisième chapitre de son
projet de loi la question de la desserte
numérique
parce que derrière le besoin de
numérique et l'envi de modernisation il
ya le tuyau il le faut absolument pas
l'air ça va moi c'est essentiel je donne
la parole au président sarkozy